évidemment on se demande un peu complexé
on a un peu jaloux par rapport à vous
recommandons va faire une interview même
rocco
est-ce que même rocco aimerait avoir un
sexe plus grands parfois écouter
dernièrement je n'ai vu quelqu'un
d'américains qui a débarqué vraiment
avec des 30 cm 3 et donc je me suis
sentie petty mais ça va bien ça va je
suis content de faire plus avec moins
est-ce que même rocco a du mal à bander
parfois oui est-ce que même rocco a du
mal à revendre et parfois plutôt ça
est-ce que même rocco a déjà pensé que
sa femme simulaient jamais est-ce que
même recours est déjà galéré pour
séduire une fille oui beaucoup de fois
est-ce que même rocco a déjà pris des
râteaux il a le mange déjà beaucoup de
fois beaucoup d'eau est-ce que même
rocco s'est déjà fait traiter de petit
beat psychologiquement oui est-ce que
même recours a déjà pensé qu'il n'est
pas que le cul dans la vie beaucoup de
fois c'est difficile est-ce que même
rocco pense que le plus important c'est
la tendresse
oui mais aussi avec le reste avec la
double peine
mais non je pense que la grèce va avec
le reste il faut jamais être dur sans
l'attendre et ça marche pas mais sont
dans des bisous avancer beaucoup mieux
c'est le secret de m corner voilà est-ce
que même récompense que les films x ont
une influence néfaste
moi je pense que comme tous les autres
choses de la vie la télé les jeux
et tout ça qu on nous montre tous les
journées c'est au même niveau je ne
pensais jamais que la pornographie c'est
éducatif éducatif mais aussi le
contraire donc je dis gdd exemple touché
à la main j'ai des gens qui me faire mal
à leurs yeux mais dis merci d'exister
moi je dis [ __ ] je suis pas dieu mais
il me dit comme ça et les jeux des
autres qui me disent mais qu'est ce que
vous faites
qu'est ce que vous faites qu'est ce que
c'est son qg les deux qu'est-ce que vous
voulez que je me dis ouais est-ce que
même rocco se dit parfois qu'il est
anormal beaucoup de choix